um I haven't we haven't talked on camera
since you made the Forbes Magazine so I
just want to say congrats that [__] is
that [__] is pretty gnarly to like be
like damn my boy like my friend is on
the cover of Forbes like you know the
cool thing about that is like there's
people that are way richer than me and
there's people that that built way
bigger businesses but to touch that
cover is like every businessman
entrepreneurs dream yeah so I have guys
like worth like hundreds of millions of
dollars that H me like dog you did it
and I'm like bro you did it [__]
no you did it for real yeah you got it
got it right now liquid but I just think
it's a it's a really cool thing to come
out of cancer and then touch that cover
and then get the add age award and get a
couple other things that we got like
it's just really cool and it's just good
U morale for like the kind of industry
I'm in I was going to say how does that
change your life being on that cover cuz
I'm sure it makes people look at you a
lot different two ways yeah no I mean
one people put more respect on the
business conversations but two everyone
thinks you just got it got it got it
like they just seen that word like $400
million they like oh [__] you
can throw me give me let me get a half a
meal let me get let me borrow
like man like man invest this 2 Mill
behind my company I know you guys like
bro like yo like this this this
valuation that they're putting on me as
a person um you know kind of like relies
on the businesses performing executing
and like you know exiting one day right
that's what the value of my business is
and kind of put a lot of things in
perspective you see even the rich rapper
list mhm that [__] was trippy to me that
[__] is crazy cuz what were you fourth
or fifth I was number four crazy and
then you put yourself next to rappers
like um [__] Dr Dre JayZ Dr Dre Jay-Z
Kanye you know Diddy and like people
like man bir's not really rapper I'm
like wait a minute hold up I do got 49
albums out I've been rapping since 2006
people are saying well he got other
businesses well so does everyone El
everybody else everybody else got you
know uh at a Time s Rock and and you
know Rock Nation and I mean yeah nothing
different Ace of Spades whatever you
call it same it's the same exact thing
except the difference is I'm Mexican and
I'm [__] low-key Underdog and so it's
it's cool as [__] to see that they
recognize me on that list because that
list I always dreamed about um about
being on a list like that and I always
said that that that people are
overlooking what I built and I just
remember one day kind of just throwing
the fit on Twitter like man I wish they
would look at my [__] and someone
actually was like well I'd be down to
audit and that's a really deep audit
they have to look at everything that you
have your assets your businesses it's
like a real they can't just put that
[__] out there to make the cash is it
the Cash Kings list is that what they
call it just the just hip hop uh you
know wealthiest whatever it may be um
top five wealthiest you know so they did
that and yeah that [__] hit so they like
really like they turn over all the pages
and look into your [__] for real for
real yeah they do like a real audit of
you for sure oh wow so it ain't no gazy
ass number going out there no no hell no
no that's that's a real number it's a
real situation it's a real it's just all
around real like they're not going to
they're not going to play you on that
like they're not going to play
themselves it's real Publications with
real credible writers and just you know
they're they're not play they're not
playing no games with that list that
list is very strategic it's very they do
a good job of due diligence you know I
have to have them talk to like business
managers and the people that do my taxes
and yeah that shit's real damn they're
like talking to the CPA and all that
[__] huh CPA are looking at like
properties they're looking at the actual
like are you say your business worth
this like let's let's do actual audit of
your business let's do you know let's
get a proper what what did you raise at
last time you raised you know like it's
it's real as [__] it's crazy because
because you've um obviously you know
we've kind of seen cookies grow from
like you know I remember the first time
I smoked cookies was with two chains in
probably
2010 shout out to titty 11 yeah that was
around the time Yoko was getting played
on the radio out there when I was on the
that was that was around that time and I
remember you'd be coming out to Vegas
kicking with Franny and [__] and um I
kind of had like really got hip to you
but it's just wild to see like the did
like was there ever a point in time
let's say in 2010 11 where you ever
could imagine that you'd be turning down
some of the exits I'm sure you've
already been offered and and and you'd
be on the cover of a publication like
Forbes did you ever see it no but I
always knew too like at the end of the
day it's all about how much work you put
into your craft right like if you stay
dedicated to your craft if man like even
last night dude I got home last night
and I just passed the [__] out hard 900
p.m. out like dead body my girls woke up
this morning you remember how you fell
asleep I'm like n she like man you were
[__] out and just because I just work
all day long so I never pictured being
in this position cuz I was always an
underdog I feel like I always had to
prove myself to somebody I always had to
work harder than others but I also knew
that like one of my first True Believers
in what I do like one of my first actual
like investors and partners and you know
he told me he's like bro like I don't
really quite know where you're trying to
go with the rap but I do know one thing
he's like bro you don't stop and people
that don't stop and don't quit are the
ones that hit so I'm going to stick with
you you should just stick with the pack
you're good at selling pack I want bags
from you and I think that you'd be
better off just focusing on selling bud
but like man you just won't stop with
this rap [__] and so I have to stay
behind you I'm going keep pushing you
because that that's what [__]
like you aren't going to lose and that's
stuck with me I'm like you're right even
the current state of cannabis right now
like the weat game is [__] up a lot of
people falling out a lot of people suing
each other a lot of people people hating
each other a lot of businesses going
under a lot of grow failing a lot of
stores failing um you know but we're
still relevant as hell we're still going
because we still put that passion into
it like we still care about this [__] do
you think it's also cuz you guys have a
dope business model I think too which is
not necessarily dependent on any because
I'm sure if people don't understand like
you guys will part like you guys have
Partners all over the country right it's
not like if you see a cookie store in
Detroit it's the same as the cookie
store in Oklahoma mhm well some and I'm
sure some places it is the same
partnership right but for you guys like
you guys have kind of like put put
together such an incredible business
model on the storefront side at least
where you know um it's a quality control
situation where you obviously have to
vet whoever you partner with but at the
same time it kind of puts you guys in a
position where you know people are
buying into the name and the brand
because the brand is so prestigious yeah
it's like asset it's a asset like
business model we're not raising
hundreds and millions of dollars which
allows me to stay in control a lot of
other people that raise hundreds of
millions of dollars they L yeah they
lose all their Equity I maintain a lot
of equity bro a lot and but what it does
is like it does three things we're able
to stay as asset light we're able to
expand faster anyone else we also able
to cherry pick the best operators in in
in each market as they open up so you
know Albert cookie New Mexico we open up
113 right November 3rd that's probably
one of our best men Us in the whole
country the weed looks almost better
than some of the weed in California the
menu is extensive 30 genetics on the
menu store fullly buil out like we got
to cherry pick those partners that were
dedicated to us Nirvana and Arizona I
was going to say it took you a very long
time to get to Arizona and that was a
passionate you know well we [__] up
the first time we did we did a deal with
the only players in the game and they
pretty much sh [__] the weed up right
they [__] the weed up but they also
shelved our growth but now we found some
independent guys that you know the team
and Nana that understand what this brand
means they put the quality and we turned
down enough batches until it was time to
go we're like bro it's not hit and it's
like boom you got it yeah and they
doubted it in and they doubted in even
more from the opening and so it allows
us to partner with the right people all
around the country and a lot of people
say it's like a franchise it's not like
a franchise because anyone could open up
McDonald's yeah you guys are being
selective on who you're going to let
we're being selective on who we're going
to [__] with we're being selective on
which Market are mature enough to open
up and we're also just really
understanding that like there's nothing
easy about managing hundreds of Partners
right it'd be easier to raise the money
and to build out your [__] yourself in
theory because then you're the one
controlling all that there's a lot of
egos there's a lot of there's a lot of
politics there's a lot of personal um
you know interaction you have to do when
you have that many partners but I like
that [__] yeah and it also kind of
removes the like bureaucracy that you
would have to deal with within each City
and Market because at the end of the day
like you said man the weed game it's
unfortunately it's full of like a lot of
cool people but it's also full like on
the corporate side bro like it's trash
bro like I missed the medical days so
much you know when it was medical it was
a big risk still and people were having
to put their neck on the line and it
just was a lot more pure as soon as it
went legal a bunch of people that had no
business being in this business got in
this business and they started getting
in you know Partnerships with Legacy
guys and kind of changing the way that
they think and what's really the real
goal I mean if you look at the two
things I'm truly passionate about food
and weed it's it's two things that
really bring people together no matter
where you're from no matter where you're
at in the world you can connect over
food or wheat right so like I'm in it
for a bigger purpose I know the brand
has value I know there's going to be
some money associated with this with
this position later on life but for
right now it's it's a struggle to
maintain to stay relevant to deal with
all these different Partners make sure
everyone's happy everyone feels like
they're getting the attention they need
but I wouldn't I wouldn't change our
business model or the situation we have
over anything it's cool to connect with
people all over the world and you said
it not just in the country but all over
the world Thailand Thailand we got
Thailand we're about to open up London
uh you know medical side of London um
we're in Spain we're in Amsterdam we're
in Israel we're selling wheat in Germany
right now like it's cool to connect with
people all over the world over over
something you created from you know the
ground up in your house mhm it's cool as
F that shit's wild man yeah